will my credit you can forget it from
now on I'm only using cash or debit take
your pasta
go ahead and shove it on like Washington
we keep a balanced budget credit ain't
cool it's a scam I'm sick of livin life
on a payment plan
we're dead
Oh
Oh
Oh
Rob and Johanna just did their debt-free
scream and then the flash mob that was
unbelievable whose idea was that that
was mine people want to know how long
did it take to pull that together it
took about three months three months how
many people helped out oh I don't know
like 30 or 40 so who are these people
who are these people that are helping
out these are a lot of my co-workers
from the radio station a lot of our
friends from church our roommate like
everybody that we could get so did you
help write the music at all what was
your I mean this is a team effort to get
debt-free I imagine it was some type of
team effort with this flash mob what was
your role um I said what are you doing
writing a song and then he produced it
and did it all and wrote it all and I
was like wow yeah okay good job I
shouldn't have doubted you okay all
right so the lyrics came to you pretty
easy I know she took a shot at
Washington DC did that feel good it felt
really good all right so really fun to
put all this together what do you want
to say to all the people who are gonna
watch this this is quite the production
I've never seen this happen for a
debt-free screen so you may have like
set the bar for creativity
what would you say throw the gauntlet
down I want to say I challenge you to do
an awesome debt-free scream but mostly
to get out of debt huge you can't say it
any better than that Robin Joanna are
debt free and you're watching the Dave
Ramsey show